après sa mort Joseph Staline décide donc
de momifier l'énine c'est le premier
coup de théâtre d'une idéologie qui in
comomble s'invent là un dieu vivant et
l'aventure à travers le siècle de cette
momie reflétera d'une certaine manière
nous non de le voir avec ce documentaire
réalisé par Xavier Viltard le destin de
l'Union soviétique mais quelle trace
laisse désormais Lénine 100 ans tout
juste après sa disparition nous allons
poser la question maintenant à nos
invités présents sur ce plateau de
dbadoc andre Kosovo pour commencer
bienvenue vous êtes historien
spécialiste de la Russie professeur
d'histoire russe à l'Université de Lille
et votre dernier livre s'intitule la
chute de l'Union soviétique
198291 2023 ouvrage publié chez place
des éditeurs on vous doit aussi tout
récemment et jérry rouge 12 femmes qui
ont fait la révolution russe un ouvrage
publié cette fois chez pin Sophie curé
est également avec nous bienvenue à vous
Sophie curé vous êtes historienne
spécialiste de l'Union soviétique et
professeur d'histoire contemporaine à
l'Université de Paris Cité et auteur
entre autres de la grande lueur à l'est
les Français et l'Union soviétique
publiés aux éditions du Seuil et réédité
chez
CNRS édition Stéphane Courtois enfin est
avec nous bienvenue Stéphan courtois
vous êtes historien spécialiste du
communisme vous êtes l'auteur entre
autres de Lénine l'inventeur du
totalitarisme publié aux éditions Périn
et puis vous avez tout récemment dirigé
cet ouvrage de la cruauté en politique
de l'antiquité aumer rouge également
disponible lui aussi chez pin on va
commencer avec vous après avoir vu ce
film entièrement consacré à à à ce
mausolé de Lénine que chacun peut encore
voir d'ailleurs aujourd'hui hein s'il
est de passage à Moscou c'est gratuit
hein c'est pas du tout un lieu
touristique en tant que tel hein en tout
cas
aujourd'hui à la lecture de votre livre
Stéphane Courtois Lénine l'inventeur du
totalitarisme votre thèse est la
suivante
finalement c'est qu'on a souvent dédoiné
Lénine pour mieux accabler stellline et
on l'a souvent fait pendant des années
durant après la fin de l'Union
soviétique d'ailleurs euh expliquez-nous
ça oui ben on tout le monde sait que
Lénine est le fondateur de ce régime he
puisqu'il était le le fondateur le chef
presque incontesté du Parti bolchevique
surtout après sa prise de pouvoir de
novembre 1917 qui était un exploit
politique absolument inimaginable
puisqu'il faut quand même rappeler que
Lénine c'est un un personnage
relativement inconnu avant cette prise
de pouvoir un sa sauf des milieux
révolutionnaires russes mais pour le
reste si si en 1914 vous demandez aux
Français qui c'est Lénine ils vont il y
a personne ne saura bon donc c'est
important déjà de de souligner ça et et
et voilà que cet homme réussi à
s'emparer du pouvoir et à s'y maintenir
bon il meurt assez rapidement on va en
parler puisqu'il est mort c'est c'est
d'ailleurs un peu pour ça qu'on fait
cette émission c'est c'est le centenaire
21 janvier 1924
après deux attaques cérébrales donc il
était très très
diminué depuis euh 1918 on y rendra pere
même oui depuis décembre depuis mai
avril mai 1922 déjà mais peu importe
hein et donc donc voilà or euh il est
vrai qu'il meurt assez rapidement et
qu'ensuite c'est un certain Joseph
dugashwiili dit Staline qui s'empare peu
à peu de la direction du Parti
bolchevique et de toute l'URSS et il va
progressivement éliminer tous ses
concurrents politiques à commencé par le
célèbre Trotski hein et et de fait
pendant toute la période stalinienne
jusqu'à la mort de Staline en 53 on a
toujours ces deux figures qui sont
Lénine et Staline et Staline se réclame
continuellement de Lénine c'est sa
légitimité bon mais c'est quand même
Staline qui est le grand homme le Dieu
vivant du communisme des années 20 30 40
et jusqu'à sa mort en 53 c'est Staline
bon hein et le petit père des peuples
come comme on l'appelait hein et puis
alors voilà que en
1956 la direction soviétique parce que
c'est pas une initiative personnelle de
krutchev c'est toute une partie de la
direction soviétique veut se débarrasser
de de la figure de Staline dont don dont
chacun sait en URSS que c'est un un
grand terroriste il a fait tuer
énormément de monde hein et que donc il
devient extrêmement gênant hein donc il
faut se débarrasser de cette figure et
crutchef en février 56 lors du 20e
congrès du Parti communiste d'Union
soviétique va faire un discours qu'on va
appeler le discours secret parce qu'il
va être en circuit fermé hein réservé au
délégués soviétiqu où il va faire une
dénonciation absolument invraisemblable
de Staline d'un seul coup Staline
devient l'homme abominable même si
krutchev se garde bien de dénoncer
réellement les grands crimes de Staline
puisque krutchev lui-même est un homme
couvert de sang puisqu'il a il a obéi au
une fois des boulot voilà
bienou nécessement lén il faut bien
qu'il y ait une figure de légitimité et
on revient donc à Lénine et à partir de
ce moment-là on assiste à un revival
pour utiliser un terme abominable un
renouveau extraordinaire du de de la
figure de Lénine hein on va on va
republier ses œuvres qui ne sont pas
complètes d'ailleurs mais même pour les
Français hein c'est c'est le moment où
on va publier les œuvres de Lénine quand
même en français 45 volumes hein c'est
pas une petite affaire voyez bon hein de
20000 pages donc voilà il y a il y a
tout un une renaissance de Lénine il y a
il y a une multiplication des statutes
de lénines qui vont s'ériger partout et
en particulier en Ukraine avec des ça va
poser des problèmes à partir de du
conflit entre la Russie et l'Ukraine la
figure de Lénine va devenir le symbole
de la Russie hein dont dont certains ne
veulent plus donc voilà et et et alors
le problème bah reste jusqu'à
aujourd'hui puisque Lénine est toujours
dans son mausolé ou hein il est toujours
là et il semblerait que les Russes a
beaucoup de difficultés à se mettre
d'accord sur qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
est-ce qu'on le sort du mausolé est-ce
qu'on pour l'enterrer comme ça a été
fait pour parler he oui bien sûr c'est
une question de fond ça a posé un
problème à Staline on a bien vu dans le
documentaire et çae aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs à Vladimir Poutine mais on y
reviendra si vous voulez bien peut-être
plutôt vers la fin de cette émission en
revanche quand on vous lit bien Stéphane
Courtois vous considérez que il a
instauré l'énine hein bien une dictature
idéologique impitoyable inventant les
concepts alors révolution mondiale
dictature du prolétariat parti état
centralisme démocratique économie
planifiée terreur de masse et aussi les
instruments pour cette idéologie parti
unique police politique Armée Rouge
goulag et donc vous dites il a inventé
d'une certaine manière et mis en œuvre
le système le plus totalitaire du début
du siècle dernier est-ce que vous
partager entièrement cette vue de
Stéphane Courtois autrement dit la
l'image de Lénine en tant que
représentation du mal en politique de la
cruauté pour reprendre le titre récent
de l'ouvrage dirigé par Stéphane
Courtois euh je dirais que oui
certainement et le documentaire qu'on a
montré s'il fallait trouver peut-être un
un petit défaut quand même ce serait de
dire qu'il a passe entièrement sous
silence je crois euh la dimension
criminogène les crimes commis à l'époque
de Staline he les Lénine excusez-moi
l'absus Lénine bien sûr le fait que
Lénine soit à l'origine réellement du
système carcéral du Goulag avant le
goulag il y a un système carcéral de
concentrationnaire à l'époque de l'énine
des listes de quotas de personnes à
fusiller à prendre un otage en fusiller
c'est Lénine hein la cruauté en
politique c'est d'abord et avant tout
Lénine la dictat du prolétariat pour
dire les choses simplement peut-être un
peu trop simplement peut-être à vos yeux
mais c'est Lénine qui a placé qui a créé
la Teka la première incarnation de la
police politique le pilier du régime et
qui a placé à la tête de cette cheeka un
certain Félix derginski c'est Lénine et
qui ancêtre du KGB ancêtre du KGB bien
sûr encêtre du NKVD sous Staline
prédécesseur pardon du NKVD sous Staline
voilà donc la dimension criminogène elle
est passée sous silence dans ce
documentaire c'est un peu dommage comme
la dernière phrase de ce documentaire
tes aventures dérisoires moi je trouve
que l'adjectif dérisoire dans cette
cette phrase est un petit peu choquant
ce n'est pas du tout dérisoire 1917
c'est une date absolument cardinale et
la révolution russe dans sa double
dimension dans son ambivalence
c'est-à-dire qu'on a eu en février mars
la révolution démocratique de février
avec la fin de la monarchie des Romanov
et à la fin de l'année à l'automne
octobre-nvembre on a la prise du pouvoir
le Poch des bolcheviques ce sont deux
révolutions qui qui montre que 1917
c'est absolument pas dérisoire ça a
marqué profondément l'histoire du monde
l'histoire de de l'Europe on en est
encore là aujourd'hui on on y on y
repense aujourd'hui ça a un impact
aujourd'hui il y a un écho qui est très
important aujourd'hui la question du
mausolé fait partie de cet écho on
pourra en reparler il y a une double
révolution en 1917 février
où on peut dire peut-être en
schématisant un peu les choses mais qu'
y a une tentative de démocratisation de
la société russe et puis la fameuse
révolution d'Octobre dont Lénine est le
symbole qui a une révolution
on peut plus violente d'abord c'est un
coup d'état on peut peut-être dire les
choses comme ça ou c'est une minorité he
qui prend qui prend le pouvoir castor un
État socialiste mais cette révolution
avec à sa tête Lénine et d'une violence
inouie tout à fait c'est c'est un coup
d'état avec à sa tête Lénine qui est
donc rentré en qui était un exilé qui
est rentré en Russie au printemps 1917 à
la faveur de cette première révolution
c'est le fameux épisode du wagon d'
plombé puisqu traverse l'Allemagne en
pleine guerre en pleine guerre mondiale
et donc Lénine en fait ce qu'il faut
voir c'est que il a un long passé de de
théoriciens et même de philosophes et de
de penseurs et d'organisateurs de de la
politique derrière lui et finalement il
a exercé le pouvoir même pas un
quinquena hein de
1917 à finalement fin 21 il était déjà
très malade et il a lutté il a lutté
pour écrire ses dernières volontés mais
il a été finalement très peu au pouvoir
il Meur jeune finalement tout à fait
donc ce qu'on voit bien dans dans le
documentaire je trouve c'est que il y a
plusieurs lénines il y a le le en
quelque sorte finalement le le Lénine au
pouvoir mais il y a aussi le Lénine
mytifié fabriqué euh le Lénine qui
devient aussi une référence et un
presque euh un modèle pour les
Soviétiques avec aussi les les réformes
sociales les les réformes qui mettent
fin au au régime au régime euh Taris
voilà tout à fait et puis euh bâtit le
exactement et puis le le dernier Lénine
c'est celui qui vient d'être présenté
c'est le Lénine dénoncé comme
totalitaire dès la guerre froide et plus
encore à partir des années 1990 quand on
a accès aux archives parce que
finalement le tome le plus peut-être un
des tomes les plus intéressants de des
œuvre complète de Lénine dont parlait
Stéphane cortois c'est celui qui paraît
en 1999 avec l'ensemble des enfin une
bonne partie des textes censurés et
notamment ces textes qui mettent en
avant des décisions extrêmement brutales
un vocabulaire très violent la la
vermine éliminé et cetera mais ce ne
sont pas non plus les seules œuvres de
Lénine hein il y a toute une évolution
de de la de la pensée de Lénine ça ça
c'est sûr donc pardà la la métaphore du
Lénine embumé éternel c'est aussi un
personnage historique complexe et je
pourrais même rebondir un petit peu sur
ce que dit Sophie curé il y a
effectivement un Lénine qu'on connaît
très mal on ne sait pas par exemple on a
oublié que Lénine c'est aussi l'auteur
d'un article qui a été publié en
décembre 1914 qui était une condamnation
sans appel du nationalisme grand russe
on est alors au début de la guerre et
Lénine qui pronne absolument
l'opposition à toute forme de
patriotisme d'union sacrée est accusé de
manquer justement de patriotisme russe
et il va écrire cet article en disant
c'est pas possible euh il va citer même
Engels dans ce chapitre dans ce texte en
disant toute nation qui opprime toute
peuple qui opprime tout autre peuple
n'est pas lib il faut donc se souvenir
de Lénine aussi comme quelqu'un qui a
très bien compris que pour réussir la
révolution socialiste ce qu'il envisage
doit faire très attention à toute
manifestation de nationalisme dans la
périphérie de l'Empire russe pour
réussir il faut se gagner tous ces
courants nationalistes y compris en
Ukraine qui sont très forts et il faut
pas il faut absolument pas refaire
l'histoire du tarisme en recréant un
empire à la tsarist d'où l'origine de
l'URSS qui il faut le rappeler est une
fédération qui fait des concessions au
mouvement nationaliste dans la
périphérie donc du pays pour les gagner
à la cause du socialisme et ce l'énine
là il est méconnu aujourd'hui il
s'inspire de la Révolution française et
de la violence de
période comme la terreur de la
Révolution française hein autrement dit
1794 ça ça a l'air avéré aussi heinoui
oui oui bien sûr de toute manière tous
ces révolutionnaires du 19e siècle
français et de tous les pays était
totalement marqué par la Révolution
française il la connaissait par cœur et
même souvent il il s'identifia un
certain nombre de ces personnages les
uns se prenaient pour Danton les autres
pour Robespierre les autres pour
Saint-Juste et cetera hein donc c ça
c'est clair et il voulait un foutinville
pour diriger la fameuse Teka évoquée
tout à l'heure par Andre Kosovo quand il
y a eu discussion entre les dirigeants
pour pour nommer pour créer cette
fameuse cheeka le 20 décembre 1917 qui
est quand même un des trois grands
piliers du régime il y a le Parti
bolchevique bien sûr il y a il va y
avoir ensuite l'Armée rouge et puis
entre les deux il y a la cheeka
c'est-à-dire l'organe de la terreur
parce que on dit une police politique
mais des polices politiques même les
démocraties ont des polices politiques
on a eu les renseignements généraux bon
que j'ai bien connu en 68 et après donc
et qui m'ont bien connu aussi bon donc
voilà mais ça n'avait rien à voir avec
la Teka la cheeka c'est l'organe de la
terreur et ça c'est ça c'est vraiment
fondamental à à à souligner hein oui
Lénine c'est un c'est un révolutionnaire
qui qui reprend une certaine tradition
russes ça c'est vrai mais c'est
peut-être d'abord surtout un
révolutionnaire européen c'est d'abord
un marxiste il connaît très bien aussi
l'histoire de la de la Révolution
française il reprend d'ailleurs certains
termes le terme d'ennemi du peuple par
exemple qui qui vient de la Révolution
française et donc c'est vrai que il va
aussi porter ce ce modèle d'une
révolution russe qui devient le modèle
pour le monde mais avec toute cette
tradition européenne et ça va être très
bien aussi c'est pour ça aussi qu'il a
été très bien reçu parce qu'il était
quand même connu des milieux
révolutionnaires européens français il
parlait c'était un polyglote c'était un
intellectuel il parlait il parlait
allemand il parlait le le français il
avait vécu évidemment en exil en Suisse
en France euh dans son petit appartement
de la rue Marie Rose dans le 14e
arrondissement à Londres et donc euh
c'est pour ça aussi que
euh Sam momie finalement elle a aussi
une histoire internationale hein puisque
on le voit un petit peu dans dans le
documentaire c'est des technologies
allemandes on disait que son cerveau
c'est un Allemand qui le fait euh on dis
le le cerveau de de Lénine euh pour
essayer de détecter s'il y avait des
signes scientifiques pour euh euh
interpréter le génie absolument donc il
devient et en quelque sorte un objet
d'étude finalement pour pour la science
internationale et aussi bien sûr un
mythe un mythe politique euh ainsi par
exemple le Parti communiste le jeune
Parti communiste français très
solennellement en 1900 dans les années
1920 va offrir un drapeau de la Commune
de Paris un drapeau rouge qu'on va
placer dans le mausolé de de linine le
premier mausolé de ine celui qui est qui
était en bois voilà donc il y a toute
cette C ces circulations avec avec le
monde révolutionnaire européen et
ensuite mondial et à propos de de de
cette fameuse autopsie hein de de Lénine
que vous évoquez je conseille la
lecture d'un article publié par un autre
historien vous connaissez bien Stéphane
Courtois qui est Nicolas Verz dans le
dernier numéro de du magazine l'histoire
révolutionnaire sous les Dar qui a à sa
manière aussi commémore ce ce centenaire
de la mort de de Lénine et qui nous
décrit par le menu ce qui a été
l'autopsie du corps de de Lénine parce
que ce corps de Lénine il a d'abord posé
un gros problème à Staline alors
peut-être qu'on on va un petit peu
rappeler le hasard le rôle du hasard
dans l'histoire juste
pour donner un exemple extraordinaire
qu'est-ce qui a fait qu'on a pu avoir le
temps euh de faire cette momie d'embumer
le corps
et bien c'est le froid le froid
aujourd'hui il fait froid en France
n'est-ce pas mais ce n'est rien comparé
pas à la fin janvier alors il est les
les funérailles ont lieu le 27 janvier
bon 1924 c'est un froid arctique et on
répétera pendant plusieurs générations
plus tard que les Soviétiques se sont
découvert ils ont enlevé leur petits
chapeau leur chapka pendant ce froid
arctique et plus tard pendant l' d'un
personnage qui m'est proche brege nef et
bien en 1982 personne se découvrira
alors qu'il fera beaucoup moins froid on
sera en novembre mais quand même il fait
froid en novembre Union Soviétique en
janvier 1924 il fait extrêmement froid
il va faire froid pendant 2 mois c'est
ce qui va permettre au corps de Lénine
de se maintenir sans trop de dégâts sans
se décomposer il y aura quelques traces
de dégradation mais pas avant la fin
mars et pendant cette période de 2 mois
et bien vous allez avoir des débats au
sein du parti communiste ils sont pas
d'accord au début sur le fait de
momifier l'enine il faut surtout pas
s'imaginer que c'est quelque chose qui
avait été décidé à l'avance et que c'est
quand même un comple sous l'idéologie
communiste de créer un dieu vivant c'est
ce qu'on nous explique dans ce film
d'ailleurs le communisme c'est une
idéologie matérialiste qui rejette toute
idée de religion la religion c'est
l'opium du peuple Lénine l'avait dit les
dieux vénérés les dieux c'est une forme
de nécrophilie il avait utilisé le mot
nécro profili il était bien sûr opposé à
toute forme de momification et et de
relique sa femme Nadejda kupskaya dont
je parle dans ce numéro de l'histoire la
famille et bien elle était évidemment
farouchement opposée à toute forme de
culte de Lénine parce que c'était
évidemment une forme de culte qui ne
disait pas son nom et donc vous allez
avoir un débat dans le documentaire on
parle du rôle de derginski comme étant
déterminant permettez-moi de nuancer un
peu il y a un certain Léonide crassine
qui a joué un rôle très important
personnage oh très important kassine qui
euh depuis longtemps nourrit l'idée du
marxisme comme une forme de religion et
qui de formation Ingénieur va s'associer
avec des spécialistes de la
réfrégération pour proposer une solution
qui sera finalement
acceptée il posera un problème à à
Lénine ce ce corps c'est lui d'ailleurs
en 1936 qui mettra un terme à toutes ces
ces analyses scientifiques sur la base
de l'autopsie de de et notamment du
cerveau de l'énine que vous l'avez dit
là il y a un moment ça pose un véritable
problème à Staline je pense que ça pose
de problèmes d'abord un problème entre
guillemets scientifique puisque
effectivement ils sont pas contentés de
d'autopsier de le cerveau de Lénine ils
l'ont découpé en plus de 30000 lamelles
pour les examiner au microscope et
essayer de découvrir les origines
biologiques du génie révolutionnaire
vous imaginez pour bon pour des
matérialistes SAF moment il a plus
besoin de ce dieu vivant qui a été créé
dans non mais le le problème c'est que
au bout de au bout de plus de 10 ans
d'études de ce cerveau on ne trouve
aucune trace du génie révolutionnaire et
en plus pour cause j'ai et pour cause et
pour cause hein et en plus les médecins
à l'époque la propagande dit oh le
cerveau de Lénine 1 kg 350 c'est
extraordinaire 1 k 350 c'est déjà le
poids d'un cerveau d'un enfant de 5 ans
he je suis allé vérifier ça et et le
poids moyen d'un cerveau c'est 1 K4 donc
le cerveau de Len était plutôt un peu en
dessous donc voilà ça c'est le premier
problème c'est ce ce cette espèce de
cirque scientifique ne donne rien et
Staline bon ça suffit bon hein et puis
il y a autre chose c'est que ce Lénine
finalement il lui prend un peu la place
hein il s'en sert bien bien sûr pour se
légitimer mais enfin en 36 Staline est
déjà en train de préparer la liquidation
de de tout tous les proches de Lénine he
ça va être les grands procès d'abord le
premier grand procès de de Moscou et
puis le deè le 3è et puis la liquidation
de tout un tas d'autres gens c'est la
purge des anciens compagnons de Lénine
les choses un maintenant ça suffit le
culte de Lénine c'est très bien c'est
très bien pour les mougiques mais pour
le on va aller on va les envoyer visiter
le mausolé mais pour le
parti l'idole l'idole vivante c'est
Staline et ça je crois que c'est très
clair oui je crois que la question qui
se pose
dans dans ces premiers débats et puis
dans toute cette ce développement du
culte de Lénine c'est moins finalement
le génie ou même la question de la
religion ou du culte c'est la place du
chef euh c'est-à-dire c'est quand même
la classe prolétarienne les ouvriers les
paysans qui prennent le pouvoir donc
a-t-on besoin de chef Lénine dit que non
que c'est le parti mais le parti en même
temps pour Lénine doit être un parti
discipliné organisé donc avec un chef à
sa tête aussi et en fait Lénine a
commencé organiser pas vraiment son
propre culte mais il posait volontiers
hein pour des sculpteurs il se faisait
photographier filmer il rencontrait des
étrangers par exemple Herbert George Wes
qu'ilappelle le rêveur du cremelin bon
ça peut on peut relire ça évidemment à
postériori les rêve de Lénine mais donc
Lénine était un homme autoritaire qui
une fois au pouvoir a pris ses décisions
extrêmement dur hein de la collectivé
enfin de des réquisitions de la de de la
terreur comm encein euh et non donc ce
qui se pose la question qui se pose
c'est effectivement euh faut-il un chef
et effectivement euh Staline va
évidemment opter pour ce régime
autoritaire voire totalitaire et donc
mettre sa propre personne finalement
comme le successeur de l'énine mais il a
besoin de l'énine et c'est vrai que
l'idée c'est moins de créer une religion
que de faire adhérer le peuple et c'est
vrai que cette immense Russie et ces
peuples aussi de l'Union soviétique hein
vont adhérer à cette image de Lenine
c'est Ilic c'est le la figure familière
c'est lui qui apporte l'électricité la
lampe d'Ilich donc ça fonctionne et
c'est aussi pour ça que ça a duré aussi
longtemps alors on en arrive à ce que
vous nous avez dit lors de votre
première intervention mais avec cette
fameuse question que faire du mausolée
de Lénine et cette question elle se pose
de manière extrêmement récurrente depuis
la chute de l'URSS
1991 et visiblement les pouvoirs qui se
sont succédés à la tête de la Russie
depuis la fin de l'Union soviétique
n'ont pas encore trouvé la réponse quel
est le problème concernant la suite à
donner à ce fameux maosolé à ce fameux
corps de Lénine que chacun peut aller
voir aujourd'hui encore s va à Moscou
alors je crois que on pourrait peut-être
rappeler que la question des corps et du
retour des corps c'est une question
absolument centrale dans la Russie
post-soviétique en 2005 par exemple euh
on a fait a rapatrié de Suisse je crois
hein le corps de c'était denikin hein le
fameux général denikin général de
l'armée blanche on a également rapatrié
cette fois je crois que c'était en en
Allemagne
euh une référence intellectuelle pour
Vladimir Poutine Ivan Eline un écrivain
très on va dire réactionnaire
comme apologette du fascisme n'est-ce
pas qui disait entre autres choses que
l'Ukraine n'avait pas le droit d'exister
de manière indépendante qu'elle avait
vocation à ne vivre qu'avec la Russie
bref on le retrouve dans plusieurs
citations de de discours de Poutine le
retour des corps y compris l'exhumation
des corps de la famille impériale et
alors bien sûr à la fin ça commença dans
les années 90 avec enfin le constat est
là on n jamais déboulonné les statutes
de Lénine ou très peu du côté de la
Russie aujourd'hui on l'a fait en
Ukraine en revanche hein ça c'est pour
la petite histoire mais en Russie les
les statutes de l n'ont pas été
déboulonné et ce mausolée est toujours
en plein cœur de la Place Rouge à
Moscou le pouvoir en place s'interroge
que va-t-on faire de ce mausolé quel est
le problème du pouvoir en placeervatisme
de Poutine c'est ça si vous voulez c'est
on conserve les différentes strates de
l'histoire russe toute l'histoire russe
mérite d'être respectés et aimé y
compris Staline dans ses excès hein euh
ils sont tous là ils doivent être
présents donc on va pas les éliminer
c'est l'image même du conservatisme
poutinien il y a évidemment un objectif
politique qui est de garder les voix des
communistes
les sympathies des voix des des
nostalgiques du communisme ou de ceux
qui considèrent encore que Lénine était
bien sûr une une figure absolument
indispensable à la construction de la
Grande Russie et il faut ici rappeler
que pour Poutine Lénine n'est pas un
personnage positif pourquoi parce que
Lénine est à l'origine de cette
fédération soviétique de cette URSS et
il a démantelé d'une certaine manière il
avait posé voilà la possibilité dès la
sa fondation en 1922 la possibilité
existait en théorie he de qui quitter
cette Union soviétique contrairement au
projet stalinien qui créait une grande
Russie et donc c'est ce qui s'est passé
en 91 l'Union soviétique a éclaté donc
pour Poutine aujourd'hui Lenine c'est un
mauvais personnage alors quel était le
problème d'elsine et quel est le
problème aujourd'hui de Poutine
vis-à-vis de ce ce fameux
mausolé j'ai j'ai spécifié qu'on pouvait
y aller gratuitement aujourd'hui parce
que en Russie on ne veut pas dire que
c'est un c'est un lieu touristique en
tant que tel où on doit payer sa place
on peut acheter des cartes postales à la
sortie c'est pas du tout comme ça que ça
se passe lorsqu'on va voir le maosolé de
Lénine alors quel est le problème du
pouvoir làdus non mais bon elsin lui a
été c'est lui c'est lui qui a fait
exhumer les restes de la famille
impériale c'est d'ailleurs lui qui en
tant que chef du Parti communiste de la
région de sverlof avait fait raser la
maison hipatiev où cette famille avait
été assassinée mais il faut bien voir
que elsine lui a construit son pouvoir
sur une opposition entre la Fédération
de Russie et l'URSS l'URSS Gorbatchev
moi elsine Fédération de Russie donc
voilà or Fédération de Russie évidemment
lzar donc on exhume on fait de grandes
cérémonies et cetera et cetera bon
ensuite ça c'est une on réhabilite
certainesar don on refait des statutes
d'ailleurs comme Alexandre i notamment
voilà alors ça c'est c'est une première
étape bon l'étape Staline elle a été
réglée déjà sous crutchef quand il a
fait sortir la momie de Staline du
mausolé pour la mettre avec d'autres
dirigeants au pied du kemelin très bien
bon on n parle plus et reste Lénine
alors que faire alors effectivement pour
pour compléter un petit peu encore ce
que dit
Andrey il faut bien voir que pour
Poutine et il l'a bien montré au moment
de de ce conflit avec l'Ukraine il a
accusé il a accusé Lénine d'être le le
le créateur de ce problème hein c'est
lui c'est lui qui a laissé l'Ukraine et
cetera indépendant ce qui est totalement
faux hein euh dès la mi-décembre 1917
Lénine déclare la guerre à l'Ukraine
indépendante donc on peut pas dire que
c'est lui qui qui la libère pas du tout
hein euh et ça bon ça évidemment c'est
la tactique de Lénine hein euh ça a été
évoqué d'un côté quand c'est nécessaire
pour sa politique pour aller au pouvoir
on critique l'empire des dzar la prison
des peuples et cetera mais dès qu'on est
au pouvoir sur d'autres euh pas du tout
sur une base nationaliste sur une base
internationaliste parce qu'il faut
jamais oublier que c'est le fondement de
la pensée de Lénine c'est comme pour les
marxistes c'est un internationalisme son
idée ça n'est pas je vais faire une
Russie socialiste ce qui a été l'idée de
Staline par la suite son idée c'était
une révolution nous allons faire une
grande révolution mondiale voilà hein
nous allons passer sur le corps de la
Pologne nous allons rentrer en Allemagne
et de là nous allons emporter le morceau
donc voilà donc Poutine pas grand fan de
Lénine mais néanmoins intouchable oui
intouchable parce que il représente
aussi he une une figure historique
effectivement c'est cette synthèse cette
espèce de syncrétisme historique où
Poutine va piocher dans certains
éléments de l'histoire c'est ce que
c'est s'expliquait André casavoy et donc
retenir chez
Lénine malgré tout hein celui qui a
sauvé
finalement l'État
nation à l'époque où il était agressé de
toutes parts et ça reprend aussi he
cette paranoïa cette idée de de
l'Occident qui encercle et et qui et qui
agresse ce qui fait que actuellement
dans les dans les régions de l'Ukraine
qui sont qui sont occupées par la Russie
on on remet des des des statuts de on
rétablit les les statuts de l'énine donc
cette cette guerre symbolique elle dit
quand même quelque chose de ce que peut
encore représenter l'énine même si pour
autant qu'il soit fiable les sondages
d'opinion en Russie actuelle montre que
la figure la la beaucoup plus populaire
reste celle de Staline mais à cause
aussi de de l'héritage de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale et de cette de cette
image de de puissance nationale ce qui
est celle sur laquelle joue actuellement
le pouvoir le pouvoir russe au
passage bon ce mausolé ce ce corps de
Lénine pose problème au pouvoir ENL et
depuis 35 ans il y a des commissions qui
ont été réuni pour essayer de voir dans
quelle mesure on pit pas en faire un
musée bon bref on avance toujours pas
sur ce sur ce dossier je je vais citer
pour finir Alexandre schumf qui est un
de vos confrères historiens et et qui
publie lui une biographie he d'ailleurs
sur l'énine et qui lui souligne que même
C ces deux révolutions de 1917 ne sont
pas commémorés aujourd'hui en Russie que
commémorer dit-il à propos de ces
révolutions de 1917 qui honorait qui
dénigrait la Révolution a donné d'un
côté l'énine et les bolchéiques qui sont
considérés aujourd'hui comme le diable
mais de l'autre elle a aussi donné
Staline qui pour les Russes fait partie
de la grande histoire officielle du P
pays depuis Yvan Le Terrible jusqu'à
Vladimir Poutine en passant par Pierre
Legrand on n'arrive pas à à avoir du
côté russe aujourd'hui une vision
apaisée de son histoire du moins pour ce
qui concerne le 20e siècle non non on
peut pas on peut pas et surtout sous
Poutine parce que 1917 c'est la
révolution c'est le chaos c'est la
destruction de l'ancien état et c'est la
construction dans le chaos dans la
guerre civile du nouveau c'est ce ce que
veut surtout pas promouvoir Poutine veut
surtout pas donner comme modèle hein le
modèle lis de la destruction d'un ancien
état de la construction d'un nouveau ça
pourrait être mal interprété c'est
Stalin le bâtisseur de l'État qui est le
modèle alors tout de même surprenant
d'apprendre qu'en Russie on ne commémore
pas la révolution et notamment celle
d'octobre 1917 aujourd'hui encore un
grand grand merci vraiment à tous les
trois d'être venu commémorer hein ce
centenaire de la mort de de lenid le 21
janvier 1924 vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtagdbadoc merci à Selma sali Sarah
Eline qui m'ont aidé à préparé cette
émission et je vous donne tout
simplement rendez-vous pour un prochain
débatoc ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à très
[Musique]
bientôt